deep in the welsh valleys there's a new
motor sport being tested
but there's no sound of a roaring engine
just as the coal mines here have been
replaced by something greener
this 550 horsepower suv
is 100 electric and behind the wheel
here in neath
a formula one world champion
jensen button will lead one of ten teams
in a new race aimed at highlighting
environmental challenges we're racing in
five different locations
around the world all locations have been
really affected by climate change
and i'm it's you know it's about
bringing awareness there's a lot of
personalities involved in the sport in
terms of
the drivers in it but also the team
owners you know you've got niko
rosberg's got a team
um lewis hamilton's got a team there's
ganassi from the states you know some
big teams racing and this brings a lot
of awareness to those areas that we're
racing
the extreme e-series will feature races
in senegal
greenland brazil argentina and saudi
arabia
with all teams made up of a male and
female driver
some of the biggest names in motorsport
will be getting behind the wheel of this
car and while it is a competition
the organizers say they have a clear
environmental message
hauling hundreds of tons of racing cars
to the edge of the amazon
or the saudi deserts carries a hefty
carbon footprint
to reduce it former cargo and passenger
line of ascent helena
will transport them to areas most hit by
climate change
and ocean plastics in senegal for
example i mean
the the beach plastics there the damage
that is being caused by man
you know it's really sad to see i was
there two weeks ago on our recce and
just walking along the beach just miles
and miles and miles
of just discarded single-use plastics we
want to change people's
a image of that and we want to be able
to tell a message to
to to stop using beach plastics in that
way the effect on the environment that
it has
and we were going to be racing right
there for jensen this
new race has pushed him closer to
switching petrol for battery power
for his own car it's bad i know but i
love the sound of an engine
um yeah i know this is the future it
really is you look at the stock of
electric vehicles or electric company
manufacturers of electric vehicles on
the road
and they're going crazy it is the future
and it's the future that we need
so yes i will go electric i just
struggle with the sound a little bit
it may sound different but the speed is
certainly there
the first race sets off in saudi in
april
dan whitehead sky news in neath south
wales